hi everyone and welcome to biology
professor today we're going to be
talking about pseudo alleles before we
get into that make sure that you know
you can get free study notes from my
channel so if you look if you use the
link in the description box below
you can get
a whole bunch of free study notes
including a pdf of today's spinal board
so today's board once all the notes are
on it and all the blanks are filled in
there's a picture of it at that location
below so check that out
also remember to subscribe so you can
get more free study videos
let's go ahead and get started
before we can really talk about
pseudo-alleles i need to make sure that
you understand
some other terms gene locus allele
once we have covered those we'll go on
to talking about what pseudo-alleles are
and the two criteria that have to be
fulfilled
for two alleles to be pseudoalleles and
then we will talk about the origin and
give an example
so let's start over here
first we'll talk about gene what is a
gene it is a segment of dna
that codes for a specific
trait
remember that in humans
we have
two versions of every gene we inherit
one version from our mom and one version
from our dad
the locus
is the physical location
of
a gene on a chromosome so like if you're
looking at a map of a chromosome
you'll you can see that you know this
gene is located here and this one is
located here and this one is located
here so the locus is the physical
location of a gene on a chromosome when
we're talking about multiple locations
like the locus for multiple genes the
plural of locus is loci so
loci is the plural of that word now
we'll talk about allele allele is where
it gets a little bit more
difficult to understand if you don't
have a strong genetics background an
allele
is an alternative
form
of a gene
so basically
certain genes
um many genes in fact can have multiple
kind of versions there are
differences in the nucleotide sequence
caused by mutation that can lead to
different forms of a gene and those are
the alleles so some of the best-known
examples are with mendelian genetics
where you think about gregor mendel and
the pea plants that he was studying
and you know there were flowers
that could be purple or white like there
was a purple allele and a white allele
for the flower color jean
and there was
green seeds or yellow seeds for the seed
color gene so the alleles are those
alternative forms or versions now if
you've got this and you're ready to move
on stay with me if you feel a little
nervous still about like the differences
between alleles and genes and what
exactly alleles are i do have another
video
that is going into much more detail on
alleles versus genes and also going over
some additional vocabulary things like
homozygote and heterozygous so check
that one out if you need a little bit
more background
if not and you're ready to keep talking
about pseudoalleles let's get to that
pseudoalleles
refer to alleles for
this is important
i'm going to put it in all caps
for different
genes so the examples i gave earlier
when i was talking about alleles over
here
being like different alleles being like
them the purple flower color or the
white flower color that's for the same
gene okay different like alternative
forms of the same gene or what we call
alleles
pseudoalleles are where we're talking
about alleles that are actually for
different genes
and fulfill both of these criteria
before we move on to talking about these
criteria i want to make sure that you
know that pseudoalleles are not the same
as
i know those sound very similar and
we're talking about genes and alleles
and pseudoalleles and pseudo genes
pseudoalleles and pseudo genes not the
same thing i do have another video
specifically on pseudo genes
so if you need to know what those are
check out that video but not the same as
pseudoalleles pseudoalleles refer to
alleles for different genes that are
first
functionally related
this means they control
similar aspects
of the same
trait
so they're not um they're not different
alleles for like the exact same gene
but they are
alleles for two separate genes
that contribute to the same trait so
we'll talk about
an example in drosophila where the trait
is the size of the drosophila fly's eyes
okay
so the same trait but they're alleles
for different genes so this has to be
true they have to be functionally
related and
they have to be located
very
near
each other on the same chromosome
such that they are considered closely
linked i'll say that again i hope you've
heard that word before in a genetics
class gene linkage
they're such that they are considered
closely linked
and rarely separated by recombination if
you need a little bit of refresher on
this i have a video uh the law of
independent assortment that's in my
excuse me
and it's in my mendelian genetics
playlist so you can check that one out
if you need to remember like what
recombination is and what
linked genes are and unlinked genes
but basically the gist of it is that
when you have i'm gonna like draw
two chromosomes here
if you've got two chromosomes
um there can be like a recombination
event where
these actually break
and then like this one connects to this
one whoops hang on
this one
and this one connects
messing up my lines here
connects to this one
and so this is something that happens in
meiosis
where you have homologous chromosomes
lined up and they can undergo this
recombination process well if you have
genes that are like on totally different
ends of the chromosome they're like far
apart they can be separated pretty
easily by recombination but if you have
genes they're located very near each
other on the same chromosome that means
they're only rarely separated by
recombination are they re-separated are
they separated by recombination yes
sometimes rarely
usually though they're so close together
that these recombination events
don't happen at the right place along
the chromosome to separate them so
usually they stay together so the result
of number one and number two both of
these criteria being fulfilled even
though we're talking about alleles for
different genes the result is that they
are almost always inherited together why
because they're not going to be
separated by recombination very often
it's only rarely that that recombination
where the chromosomes like break and
like switch arms with each other
that's going to happen between these
alleles really really rarely because
they're like right next to each other
along the chromosome
so they're almost always inherited
together
and they appear to act
as a single
gene
why do they appear to act as a single
gene well they're almost always
inherited together and they're right
next to each other and they're
functionally related so they control
very similar aspects of the same trait
and so typically
they are inherited together right like
both of them inherited or neither one of
them inherited and when they're
inherited together they do such a
similar thing that it's almost like it's
just looks like it's one
one gene that's acting instead of the
fact that it's actually two pseudo
alleles
now you might be asking where these comp
where do these things come from well
they probably form following
gene duplication
events
so this is when like you know maybe like
the polymerase slips a bit and like
copies a gene twice by accident or when
there's like an uneven recombination
and the result of that is that one
chromosome ends up with like two copies
of a gene
when those two copies used to be on
different chromosomes so those would be
gene duplication events
and in this case
if you've had a gene duplication event
where you've gone from like one gene
controlling a trait to having like a
second gene right next to it controlling
a trait
well
one of those genes the duplicate
might then be able to evolve
evolve a different but similar function
so if i kind of hold up my two
you know pretend genes again we had the
original it got duplicated again
probably by
these not lining up quite correctly
but you've got the duplicate and then
the duplicate can mutate a little bit
maybe it has a nucleotide or two or
three the change maybe this happens over
time but it can evolve a different
but similar function
so my favorite example of pseudoalleles
is with the star and asteroid alleles
and drosophila
now these are
abbreviated as a capital s for star
and an ast
for asteroid
these are alleles that are at two
separate loci okay so they are at two
separate loci they're on the same
chromosome but they're in two locations
remember loci the singular there is
locus the physical location of a gene on
a chromosome so these are these alleles
are at two
different
locations on the chromosome again
probably one is a duplicate of the other
and the second one evolved a little bit
different function
but they're very closely linked like
they're so close together that they're
almost never separated by recombination
are they sometimes yes but it's rare
so two separate loci but closely linked
and they are functionally related they
both
in slightly different ways
um because they're not the exact same
gene right they're alleles for different
genes but they both make the eyes
smaller
so they meet both of these pseudoallele
criteria and that they're almost always
inherited together and they appear to
act as a single gene so we see a size
trend here this plus slash plus refers
to drosophila flies that have
um two alleles that are for like the
wild type that's not a word i've used in
this video yet
but wild type basically means like the
most common or the most typical
um allele that's out there so and again
um you know these flies they're sexually
reproducing like humans so they have two
alleles from each parent we talked about
that over here so if the fly has two
wild type alleles they have the largest
eyes but you can see like once they've
got one of these star alleles their eye
gets a little bit smaller if they've got
a couple of asteroid alleles instead of
wild type or star the eyes get even
smaller
if they've got a star allele and an
asteroid allele you've got the smallest
eyes in this kind of
size range
and so this shows you how complex the
pseudo-allele
inheritance is right it's not just about
well the eyes are normal size or they're
small no there's a range depending on
exactly which pseudoalleles
have been inherited and again whereas
they are usually inherited together they
can sometimes be separated by
recombination and that's why you can
have some of these different
combinations as well
so that was a lot thank you for watching
today remember to subscribe remember to
go to that link in the description to
get your free study notes and i will see
you next time thank you for watching
biology professor